salut aujourd'hui c'est le jour où je
suis de plus à la bourre pour faire la
vidéo pourquoi parce que j'ai rater mon
train ce matin je suis en date
aujourd'hui avec mister diable other
guys heures on est du côté de rochefort
dans le 17 je vais jouer ici et pour la
première fois en trois ans de tournée
j'ai rater mon train alors en vrai ça va
parce que j'étais hyper large sur le
temps du coup j'ai pris un train trois
heures et demie après mais le temps que
j'avais prévu pour faire la vidéo ici
aujourd'hui était un petit peu compromis
mais ça va j'ai encore dans le timing
mais c'est juste juste je pense que je
vais mettre la vidéo en ligne à 17h
vraiment tout pile aujourd'hui il ya
quelques jours je vous ai fait une trou
story et vous avez dit si on dépasse les
3000 pouce en l'air alors j'en ferai une
nouvelle je regardais ce matin on est à
plus de 6000 déjà alors c'est parti pour
une nouvelle true story je vais vous
raconter ce qui m'est arrivé hier soir
comme quoi c'est hyper freda hier soir
donc j'allais feu sur le plateau de la
nouvelle scène c'est une péniche théâtre
qui est sur la scène et yacine belhousse
qu'organiser un plateau qui s'appelle la
première fois et le but de ce plateau
sais que tu vas sur scène faire quelque
chose d'inédit que tu n'as jamais fait
donc mois pour tester un morceau du
nouveau spectacle c'était l'idéal
j'arrive là-bas je descends loges il ya
déjà du monde je dis bonjour à tout le
monde des gens que je connais des gens
que je connais pas dont deux filles et
deux mecs qu'ils sont en train de
discuter ensemble de tout et de rien et
surtout de trucs par rapport à la scène
de comment jouer sur le jeu et c est ce
qu'on prend qu'une des jeunes femmes
l'eurasienne en l'occurrence n'a pas
tellement l'habitude de monter sur scène
et on se met à discuter tous les deux de
deux des petites astuces qu'elle
pourrait utiliser pour se sentir plus à
l'aise et est encore plus sincère dans
son jeu et je me dis je connaisse est
cette personne
son visage me dit quelque chose persuadé
de l'avoir déjà vu quelque part qu on
s'est croisé qu'on a joué ensemble il ya
quelque chose c'est sûr j'ai j'ai un
souvenir avec elle est impossible de
remettre la main dessus
on continue de discuter et puis je lui
demande pas en fait je pose pas la
question de wes qu'on s'est vus j'ai
vraiment l'impression de te connaître
parce que je veux j'ai peur qu'elles
prennent ça pour la drague mal placé
donc je lui pose pas la question puis à
tout le monde et puis je me dis ça va me
revenir en a forcément fait une scène
ensemble un jour et yacine belhousse qui
organisait plateau et qui présentait
qu'ils descendent un moment donné dans
les loges et qui me présente un peu plus
officiellement acquis fait à bas ces
lignes je te vois fabien fabien céline
ans céline elle est un petit peu flipper
parce que c'est c'est que la deuxième
fois qu'elle monte sur scène
ne t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer
cette super il s'en va donc je me dis
non c'est pas rencontrés sur scène
puisque c'est que la deuxième fois
qu'elle monte sur scène c'est quand même
très très récent tu vois je me dis
qu'elle fait des vidéos sur internet
aussi et que je sais pas que j'ai vu
passer ces vidéos j'étais pas très loin
des bref au final je n'ose pas lui
demander d'où est ce qu'on se connaît je
me dis on en parlera après quand boire
un verre après les spectacles c'est pas
bien grave et le spectacle commence et
tout le monde passe moi j'étais en
dernier donc j'écoute et les autres
depuis la loge et tous les autres eux
étaient en salle en train de regarder le
spectacle est quelqu'un déboule dans les
loges c'est mon autre pote que vous avez
déjà vu aussi sur la chaîne au tout
début de l'année qui s'appelle marie
n'gbo sont donc elle descend elle était
au téléphone qu'elle était en train de
répéter elle aussi c'était un nouveau
texte forcément et pm10 acquis c'est que
sur scène fait rage ces puces et céline
faye à 2 céline ce soir et j'ai mangé
sans une famille s'est battue c'est la
jolie asiatique était là elle me dit ah
oui katsumi et oui c'était 4 subie
c'était vraiment katsumi alors pour ceux
qui connaissent pas katsumi elle a fait
une carrière dans le x dans la
pornographie et ensuite elle était
productrice et maintenant à se lance sur
scène elle tente l'aventuré du one man
show et moi je l'avais pas reconnu et je
suis tellement content de ne pas avoir
sorti cette fameuse phrase de méons ce
qu'on se connaît de quelque part je t'ai
déjà vu tu fais pas des vidéos sur
internet ou un toit comme ça toi aussi
tu imagines ça aurait été la honte de ma
vie donc je suis passé à deux doigts de
la honte de ma vie et même cette phrase
là elle fait chelou du coup dans le
contexte je suis passé pas loin de la
honte de ma vie je n'ai pas reconnu
katsumi d'ailleurs son sketch était très
drôle je les ai entendus à travers le
rideau c'était c'était vraiment chouette
mais voilà je me suis marré et depuis
hier je me marre là dessus du coup ce
sera ma trou story du jour bon par
contre je me dis pour la prochaine trop
story là il faut que je mette la barre
beaucoup beaucoup plus haut
j'avais dit 3 milles vous êtes à six ou
sept mille pousse la soie dernière vidéo
je vais doubler ce que vous avez fait
prochaine true story elle sera à 12000
parce que j'ai plein d'histoires
d'intéressant dans ma vie mais j'en ai
pas non plus assez pour en faire une
tous les jours en tout cas je crois pas
que ça vous intéresserait donc on va
dire à 12000 pouce en l'air je vous
ferai une trou story voile c'est plus
simple j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu petit teasing demain je vous emmène
à prendre des décisions comme si vous
travaillez pour la police voilà c'est un
petit indice sur la vidéo de demain
passer une excellente journée
si ce n'est pas déjà fait n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner avant de partir puisque
le mental bugs et une vidéo par jour
pendant un an dix premiers
envier au 31 décembre donc rendez vous
demain à 17 heures ciao